well
[Music]
hello, happy Friday, December 11,
andrés gonzález greets you and these are the
most important news of the day.
Family members and the entire community
remember today the five cyclists who
died hit by a truck
on Thursday, the accident happened
yesterday morning  On Highway 95 south of
Bulger City, not far from Searchlight,
despite the fact that the group was
escorted by a safety car, the
five cyclists died after being
struck by a truck that
veered out of its lane and were struck by the
driver of  the van showed no
signs of driving under the influence and
is cooperating with authorities in
the investigation members
of valley cycling groups will celebrate the lives
of their teammates tomorrow at a vigil
and recount of votes from the close
race for the seat of the
county commission for the district
ends today democrat brad miller has
so far beaten anthony by just 10
votes  Antonio would have requested a new
election, a petition that was denied,
however, a recount of votes was approved,
which began last Monday, a
spokesman for the
Clark County voter registrar said that they hope to
finish recounting the votes on
time today.
Nevada continues to surpass the number
of coronavirus cases per person
according to the latest report by
the
Nevada virus team The state added more than
50 deaths from the coronavirus on
Wednesday This number exceeds
any since it began  the
pandemic
these numbers now also surpass
those of neighboring states such as california and
arizona
the head of nevada state schools
is urgently calling on
state legislators and leaders to
develop standards to help guide
state school districts to
reopen schools
georgieva added that she is convinced
that distance learning is  This is
hurting the students of the
state, specifically
low-income students,
and let's see the temperatures for today and the
weekend in the extended forecast,
we continue with high cloudiness with a
maximum of 58 degrees and a minimum of 33
for tomorrow Saturday the 60th and  53 for
Sunday with light winds I wish you an
excellent weekend informed you by
andrés gonzález and this was the long-suffering
the news now in Spanish
[Music]